hello dudes and uh that's today we are
going to take a look at
hikaru nakamura against wesley
soh and um status quo
is that um nakamura needs to win
he needs to come back in the match
somehow and this is
um a game where he goes all in he does
his best
but is it going to be enough to take
down wishlisto who has been incredibly
solid
it certainly won't be easy and let's see
what happened in
in the game so nakamura continues with
e4
e5 and he changes things up here
and he plays the bishops opening with
bishop c4 in
this position a very interesting
decision
he doesn't think that he gets enough
after the normal knight of three
knight c6 bishop c4 i do not think he
was too content
so he decided to play um play something
else
with a bishop c4 here so knight of six
is the main line
e3 i believe magnus played this with
white as well
i can't really remember which game that
was maybe it even was nakamura against
magnus
i can't recall it but this is what
happened
but here the black player in that game
i don't i have no clue actually but they
played c6 which is the main move
however wesley so plays something else
which is knight c6 this is the other
the other main move which again could
transpose to an italian with knight f3
bishop c5
but nakamura instead he plays the extra
option
or one of the extra options with um
knight c3 which is a diff
which is a very interesting choice the
position now becomes quite reminiscent
of a vienna
which i can quickly show that is e45
knight c3 knight f6 bishop c4
and you can see that it's very very
similar the plan is f4 often
these positions are very interesting and
very sharp
knight e5 is one of the main moves here
and that is also
what um wesley does here plays knight a5
and um it's very interesting
nakamura doesn't care i think queen f3
here is
a move i mean i've played the vienna a
lot myself
due to one of my friends did the show me
that back in the days
so queen f3 here i believe is very
interesting but 92
as well is certainly not a bad try
the point is the black white doesn't
really care about this pawn structure
which
you know on the first look it does um
it doesn't look so good for white and
indeed
i don't think white has a huge advantage
but it's a position where it's uh
surprisingly unpleasant to play black
it's not so
simple because you want to play d5 but
this move is very hard to achieve i have
bishop g5 you can often play queen d3
and rook tv one
and you're pretty much never going to
play play d5 and that's very annoying
another thing is that if you play c6 i
can even play rook t1 and bishop a3
and d6 will become weak so i understand
that wesley and steady went for c6 here
now d5 it could come with a tempo in
some lines
so nakamura he chooses to avoid that and
he plays
bishop e3 of course there was nothing
wrong with
a norman move like castles what do you
want for bishop to e3
bishop b3 d6
castles the plan here is f4 which we see
here
it makes sense to try to open up the
position a little bit
maybe even potentially push f5 but that
is a move you got to be a little bit
careful of
because if i'm able to control the black
squares here
then i'm going to do well as black for
example castles f5 i would then simply
be able to play something like
98 and then i could play bishop g5 in
the future
of course in this in this case it's not
such a big of a deal for white
imagine that i play f f5
let's say i do something like this and
then i play h3
and something like v8 just making a move
here
and then g4 then it could be a big deal
that i'm able
that i get excellent control of the the
black squares here
of course this is quite unrealistic just
trying to prove a point
nakamura plays uh h3 he wants to avoid
all the
g4 nonsense bishop g4 even knight g4 in
some very rare cases but
it's not entirely impossible the black
gets queen b6 and knight g4 and some
in some line so h3 is a prophylactic
move maybe even
play g4 in the future
so uh wesley doesn't want to sit and
just wait he wants to strike
and do something and his move is great
he simply takes on f4
that takes f f4 and d5 so this changes
the position a lot it changes the pawn
structure
it changes the course of the game as
well it
changes everything and um i think it was
a good choice
and the computer also approves as you
can see there on the bar
and nakamura takes on d5 knight xp 3 8
xb3 c65 so what do we have now we have
two knights here
and then we have the bishop here for
black but
uh this pawn here is slightly slightly
weak
so you could say that black white could
be
slightly slightly better i'd say it's
just
uh roughly roughly balanced here
with chances for both sides so queen f3
attacking the pawn
it should be six defending it and
very interesting position we have here
and the question is how do you continue
as
as white and it's not so very very easy
but i think the plan nakamura comes off
comes up with is quite good he plays
knight e2 here
he simply wants to put his knight on d4
queen c7
and knight d4 so this is indeed a good
way
to go even c3 here was possible but i
like uh i like knight d4
it's a very logical move um
yeah so it's not a he's not afraid of
bishop c5 if i
if uh black does this we can always play
bishop e3
and remember we can't really take here
because then i'll take back
and we take c2 is met by bishop xf6 and
the game is over
actually the advantage is like plus four
here which is crazy but it makes
it makes sense considering that you know
if you move the knight i get knight h5
and i'm threatening a lot of things here
well bishop takes f6
so you have to protect the knight and
then i win this pawn for example
but that's uh i i digress so bishop d7
knight e2 from nakamura and i'm not sure
about that move
i'm not that sure although it does make
quite
quite some sense maybe it's better to
play c3 b4 and rush b3
something like that i think white is
doing pretty well here that's a nice
position
but he plays knight fe 2 with the plan
of perhaps bishop f4 bishop g5
something like that so a5 comes taking
some space
c3 now tightening up here
getting more control on on the on d4
rookie eight king h1
a prophylactic move move the king out of
the
diagonal there are no checks nothing and
something like knight g3 here would have
been possible as well
of course bishop f4 but king h1 is a
it's an alright move
rook a6 that is a move i like very
creative and the point is that we now
guard f6
very nicely with the rook and in some
cases rook b6 is possible attacking the
pawn and b
b3 and the knight could also move and
then
black would play rook f6 so rook a6 is a
good move at rook f6 i mean
so rook a6 great move bishop f4
bishop d6 rook f2 nakamura tries to
double
triple actually in the f file
not a bad way a way to go b5
and nakamura he doesn't have anything to
lose
it's all or nothing so he decides to
play uh play g4 and it's a very
interesting choice
the question is it good is it
objectively good or is it simply
not good enough well it's not a bad move
the best move is perhaps to play b4 here
trying to clear things up
knight b3 could come and stuff so a4
makes uh makes some sense
you do not really want to play something
like this because then i can take here
and the black is doing very badly his
pawns are very very
weak so you do not want to do that so
b4 is a good move so black should then
play uh play a4 and then something like
bishop takes d6 queen takes d6 you know
it is that black is
he has to defend quite a bit this is
pleasant for whites but
as a matter of fact it's not more than
slightly better however i will say that
i think it's
impractic practically speaking it's
probably
clearly better but anyway
so g4 bishop takes f4
knight x f4 rook e5
defending the pawn and d5 once again the
plan with v4
is certainly possible but not gonna
replace rook g1 he wants to play
g5 and it's an aggressive move
uh definitely is queen g3 was also
interesting to take this
diagonal slightly tricky way to play and
you're also
trying to play g5 so if nakamura wanted
to play g5 that badly he should have
played queen g3
because he now also has potential
tactics here
uh which could uh lead to problems for
for wesley and indeed i think his
position is fairly okay here but it went
for rookie
rook g1 h6 is the logical way to stop um
stop g5 so nakamura he keeps going at it
he plays
uh he plays h4 very interesting
he's going to play g5 next and then
perhaps even g6
and if possible take on d5 queen c8 is a
good defensive move by by wesley and the
point is that if i play g5 right now
black gets knight g4 and this is
something you can't allow
and that's why nakamura plays rook fg2
which is indeed the best
move in the position unfortunately for
nakamura he
is simply too slow here so so plays
g5 and there are no g5
breaks any longer takes rook takes and
the black is starting to
to get a comfortable position here it's
not so
easy to play to play white look at how
the pieces participate in the
in the defense area rook and a6 in
particular very strong
and then all of the other pieces are
pressuring the g4 pawn
it's a very um very good position for
black
or the objective evaluation is equal but
the position i'd say is much easier to
play
play for black so let's see what
nakamura did he played knight h5 and
this is a massive blunder i'm not
sure what he missed but
especially simple it takes the pawn i do
not see what he miss
missed um so you should have played
something like
queen e3 or whatever but this is a move
you do not want to make
the point is that if i take here with
the knight i can play rook queen e7
and um well the position is very tricky
but
here it's not so easy to find a move for
black i'll play something like rookie
one next and i have a lot of pressure
it's kind of a computer way to play
uh and you can see it's uh it's not easy
to play it
to play white and nakamura he
misses the mark with a knight h5
so knight takes g4100 was possible um so
rook takes g4
rook takes g4 knight f6 can simply be
taken
by the rook maybe he forgot he forgot
that this rook covers f6
it's not impossible that he did that but
this position here is
not very good for for white
uh his king is far too weak and he's
upon down
as well and the position is lost
objectively speaking so nike murray
decided to
go back he didn't have any other choice
and now the position has become awfully
winning
for wesley so who would be doing
extremely well here if he did win this
the nakamura would have to win the third
game of black and the fourth game with
white in order to
stay in the match rook f1 played
b4 trying to open things up a little bit
more
take six and yeah look at all of these
weak pawns
for for whites it's not looking very
good for nakamura as it plays queen g3
queen c7 by by wesley there's a lot of
pins going on here
so i'm not going to replace knight d e2
protecting both the knight and queen
queen e5 centralizing the queen d4
attacking the queen
queen e4 pinning the rook knight e3 is a
threat
so rook f3 is forced in order to prevent
that king h7
moving the king out of the way here
king g1 bishop g5 attacking the knight
kh1 it's not it's very difficult to find
a move here for
for white so black white just moves back
and forth
here at a simple way to play simply to
take the knights
black white is forced to take with the
rook and then
take another pawn i mean white position
as crumbling here and the advantage is
as high as
14 pounds for wesley selkier that's
crazy but you can't really do anything
special queen d1 is coming and
it's very difficult to find a move rook
h5 could come like if i play rook f1
rook h5 is very strong
and i can't take because i take here
so i have to play king king g2 but then
rook h2
wins the game for for black but actually
played bishop d7
king g1 who should be five and then he
actually took
so my bad he actually decided to go for
this
and hilariously enough rick takes e2
queen b1 so he should have simply
grabbed the pawn there but he didn't he
played the queen b1
rookie one so he takes this pawn instead
certainly not a bad way to go
not h3 g6 knight e4
and i think wesley didn't really find a
continuation here
because he makes a very bad blunder
it makes a very bad blunder which
changes the game entirely
so let's see what happened here so
instead it plays knight e5 and now the
game is
completely equal it's uh
quite fascinating how things can change
so a simple move like rook g8 should be
good enough
because now knight h5 is not possible
because i take
and they made this coming on h2
so you don't have many moves maybe rook
f1 and then i'll take on d4 and
it's completely lost more or less but
actually he doesn't he doesn't do that
it plays knight e5
and that is a blunder because of knight
takes g6
knight takes f3 and i think wesley must
have overlooked something
maybe knight f8 and then knight g7
uh why that's a funny trick i'm sure
that's what wesley overlooked and you
can simply play knight g6 back with
with a draw because if black takes i'll
play rook e8
check king h7
king g7 g8
king takes and i'll simply play queen b8
and queen h8
and it's stalemate it's a very nice
trick
uh nakamura went for 97 but the result
is more or less the same
wesley played a rookie six but if he
plays with g6
then well i can also take the knight but
the easiest way to draw is to do the
same thing
play rook g8 then queen b8
king h7 knight f6 check king g7
queen g8 then take here and it's going
to be
stalemate and
you can't really escape with the king
and this is stalemate so very nice a
theme here
rookie 6 by wesley but this position
here is a draw
queen takes d4 and white can take the
draw whenever he wants to he decides to
check for
for quite some time they check back and
forth but there is never
any way to get through there
it's too hard to do anything with the
queen and knight here unfortunately for
nakamura
and uh the game ends in a draw let's
just quickly see what happened here
they just move back and forth a little
bit and
at the end nakamura decides to take that
pawn and then he offers a draw
he realizes that there is nothing he can
do but he's lucky that he
didn't lose which he kind of would have
deserved
to do to to do i guess not h5
was too careless i'd say
but it happens he had to win he pushed
he did everything he could but
actually still defended very well the
best chance he had earlier was probably
to play b4
i think his position is very nice if he
does this
and then it's unpleasant for black i
think
later on i don't do not think really he
had any chances
which lisa played very very well and um
he missed the win fortunately for
for wesley it was enough nakamura he
threw the third game he also threw the
fourth game
so the final which will be played out
later today
will be uh wesley so against the world
champion magnus carson so do stand
to so do stay tuned for that and thank
you for watching